hey and welcome back to Rolla Kosek in
three and yeah I'm not addicted to pork
attacks don't worry about that I'm
actually still playing roller coaster
get three and I will be doing that since
roller coaster Zico three is really
something that I play to make creative
stuff I just kind of like it it's it's
kind of like drawing to me really that
kind of feel like I kind of want to make
some buildings is sort of like I'm gonna
draw some buildings I can't really
communicate it too well but it's
basically roller coaster country really
has that sense of realism and there are
so many things in roller coaster and
three that you can't that you can do in
roller coaster three but you can't do in
polka tectum will never be able to so I
don't think that politics is ever gonna
fill up any sort of gap that roller
coaster can three might leave if I stop
playing the game I just kind of like
Park attacked a lot and yeah that's
pretty much about that and also I do
have to say about this episode that it's
not quite too interesting really since
like I said I'm sort of stuck on the
English area as you may know there are
no custom scenery sets for this theme
whatsoever which is quite aggravating
since I just really need those details
and this wasn't really too big of a
problem up to now since I just want to
get the basic textures and shapes of the
buildings out there but now that it is
actually gonna come down to the details
and I actually wanna have some realistic
windows and realistic looking things and
just want to get that British feeling to
these buildings it's gonna be pretty
tough to actually make that work so in
the next like episode I'll get a couple
very simple Tudor wooden beams but
that's really all I'm gonna do I'm just
gonna have to try to actually make this
area look English with their details
from going through many sets and going
through many sets is already what I'm
sort of doing in this episode which is
why my really my progress on this theme
won't be too quickly and it's really
because and this is something that I
actually feel like some people don't
realize is actually a very important
thing to do sometimes you just have to
go through all your sets especially if
you have like hundreds of them because
you can't remember whatever was in every
single set and just kind of scroll
through them discover some stuff laugh
at what kind of
stupid stuff there isn't some custom
scenery sets but in general just find
out what sorts of pieces you've been
missing and what you can actually use to
make a certain theme look better and not
only is it kind of good to find pieces
that you you don't even know about or
forgot at some point it's also just good
to kind of move on to different sorts of
pieces because I always find for myself
that if I you know start building
buildings just again and again using the
same different sets and trying to stay
inside my comfort zone I end up using
the same different pieces all over the
place and I definitely want to avoid
that so jelly's episodes it can be quite
full of experimentation and just going
through them random sets and checking
out what I can actually do on buildings
which is why it's a little bit slow like
in this entire episode which still took
about two hours to record I only managed
to get like one extra building done in
terms of shape and just a couple of
details and really not that much more of
course I do hope that the well progress
that I make in the next couple videos
it's gonna be better than this but I
have to be quite honest about this it's
not really too great it was enjoyable
and that's something that no I can't lie
about but it's not really the thing that
I feel like would be the best for time
lapses but then again I sort of promise
to not skip anything and I hey I suppose
it's still better as time lapses than it
is in real-time footage so I figured
that I would actually take this bit of
time as I'm trying to build that little
English house over there and you can see
rebuilding it every damn time to
actually talk about a subject which I
haven't really talked about too much but
people always trying to get me to talk
about which is like the big elephants in
the room for wherever I go right now
which is well the coaster tycoon world
and the first is planet coaster and it's
something that I don't feel like doing a
separate video of at least not at the
moment but it is something that I kind
of want to get out there and at least
sort of inform people about with my
entire thing is about that just to get
that out of way so people that so that
everyone knows it and what pretty much
my plans are for this channel and stuff
it's um I'm sort of in the middle of
rollercoaster tycoon world
and planet coaster though I have to say
I'm definitely drifting towards planet
coaster but that's due to a number of
reasons but I just feel like roller
coaster in the world especially with
that beta and I've pretty much seen
about everything there is to see about
both games
well ago second world it's just too
unfinished way too unfinished I'd
actually rather have them move back the
release date a lot more than it
currently is but there are too many way
too many reasons for that to explain
that I can just get out in a couple of
minutes but yeah that's basically my
short thoughts about that so if I'm
gonna get it I am not really sure I'm
just gonna wait roller coaster tycoon
world I'm planet coaster both outs until
we know more about them and only if I
really feel like they'll become games
that I like playing but also tools which
I can actually make some good videos
with then I'll actually get them and
otherwise not so I'm not gonna get them
just to show them off or review them or
anything like that I'll leave that up to
other people I'll just get them if I
think it's worth it and if I can make
some good stuff with it and that pretty
much goes for planet coaster 2 which I
am slightly drifting towards because I
feel like the entire more informal and
straight to the points and more more
passionate I would even say community
interaction or frontiers a lot better
and it just seems like they're they've
got their priorities more set up
straight but yeah it's in general it's
really just a little bit of a biased
thing which is why I don't like to talk
about it too much I just kind of drift
towards frontier more because of Ataris
recent track record and frontiers recent
track record and the way that they've
been communicating on the forums and on
Facebook and stuff like that is really
awesome and they seem like really
awesome people it's kind of I'm getting
poetic vibes from that which is a good
thing but yeah that's pretty much about
that I suppose I'll take it back to
rollercoaster kin 3 for now and leave
that subject be until it's like some
really big news comes out or I get the
games which is when I'll actually be
talking about them
I might actually pick up the roller
coaster kin world new beta that will
come out but I'm really unsure about
that in any case have this building over
here was a bit of a painful thing like
that little one on the side completely
I wanted to turn that into a English pub
but I have no idea whatsoever what sorts
of sets I can use for that type of thing
like I went through many Google Images
searches on this stuff to actually find
images what I wanted to get in this park
but especially for that pub I just
couldn't find the elements that I needed
to actually get a realistic British look
going so I'm really not sure about that
I'm not gonna make us some scenery
because I suck at that and I'm Way too
lazy for it but if anyone actually has
any suggestions and I'd almost feel bad
about this but if anybody has any ideas
on how to get a really good English pub
look going because I'm not quite too
sure
then I'd be really happy to actually get
some suggestions because I'm sort of
running out of ideas that being said I
do think I'm gonna recheck out the let's
play that mask done at 102 actually put
out because it did have some Chicago
facades with some pubs in it which
actually did have some pretty good sort
of bottom facade pipes with windows and
doors and at least sweet-looking
pub front doors stuff how do you even
call those things I mean know the Dutch
for it that's pretty awkward in any case
that's pretty much the planning for that
I think next video I'll just be building
these buildings as well I'm trying to
finish that up
and after that I'll maybe you head into
interiors if I already want to do that
and see if I can actually get a gift job
going perhaps some toilets because so
far I've just been slapping toilet signs
onto buildings just get run the building
slap a toilet sign onto it and it's like
yep that's a toilet no now I don't have
to worry about people calling me out or
not having toilets in my Park anymore
but I feel kind of guilty about that so
I might also want to actually have some
real toilets in the park but yeah after
all that stuff is done I'm gonna work on
the dark rind at least that's the
current planning I'm sort of looking
forward to it
well for one I'm looking forward to
being out of this park file you don't
see the fraps frame rates in the corner
of the screen because it doesn't
actually record that when you're
recording but it's very low especially
in this park in this book this section
of the park it's not even that bad it's
about 10 FPS usually but when i zoom out
it
just instantly drops the three FPS and
not only is that a bit painful to work
with I'm really starting to worry about
the health of my computer and this park
over here and whether I'll actually be
able to finish one half of the park and
there's one workbench but that's that's
really for now it's just a worry that
I'll worry about later because up to now
I'm pretty much this having the
mentality of I'll just see wherever this
Park stops responding and until that
happens I'm not even gonna think about
it hopefully it's gonna be very far away
and I don't have to worry about that yet
but um yeah at any given moment this
park might just completely give up on me
I think it's about 15 MB right now which
is 5 MB over the recommended Park for
Hill sighs and that's really bad so yeah
I'm starting to worry about my let's
play Park over here and but hopefully
it's gonna survive and I'm see I see
that I'm running out of time over here
already and I've run out of things to
say as well so that's that's awesome
thank you for watching guys and I'll see
you guys in the next episode in which I
actually can't even remember what I did
in that one like I've already recorded
it but for the life of me I don't even
know what I'm gonna do in that one so I
suppose you'll see see you later